I believe I believe as a Muslim that all
prophets are sinless. They are unable to
sin.
What does this verse say? Does this
verse say they're
listen
if all if all prophets are sinless? How
can he sin?
Because all prophets are not sinless.
Hello guests.
Hello.
Momo, are you a Muslim?
I am.
Welcome to the panel. Lean, are you a
Muslim? Lean, can you hear me? Okay, she
went on pause. All right,
I can. Yeah, I'm Muslim. Alhamdulillah.
All right, perfect. Welcome to the
stage, ladies.
Welcome. Um, so, so you said that if I
can change your mind about Islam, you'll
become a Muslim.
Yeah. There's one thing that'll change
my mind. You want to hear it?
Go ahead.
All right. The Quran says in chapter
61:6.
Okay.
It says that Jesus mentioned a messenger
named Ahmed to come after him.
Okay. So all I want
asking for is for someone to show me
where Jesus actually said this.
You want me to prove to you that Jesus
actually said this?
Yes.
Okay, cool.
So I'm going to just start talking and
if you get confused. Yeah. Get
convinced. You get convinced. If you
don't, it's okay. All he died to whoever
he wants to.
Oh, we're going to lose you. God logic.
You said that you're just going to start
talking and then if I get confused then
you know
I said if you like if you if you convert
if you it's up to you. Allah gives haya
to who he wants to.
Well so
right on life you're going to get the
haya right on life
Allah wills. I mean
I hear you. So so you're going to show
me where Jesus said off
I'm going to prove to you to like I'm
going to prove to you to what he said is
true. Okay. Let me ask you. It sounds
like you're gonna go from the angle that
that you believe that the Quran is true
and you know so whatever the Quran says
it's it's it's true, right? Cuz the
story
not precisely. So you believe in for
example the the ship story where uh like
the bu the ship was built and the flood
happened this and that.
Correct.
Yeah.
Okay. We believe that too. Okay. So in
the Quran, right?
Mhm.
There's lo loads and loads and loads and
loads and loads and loads of stories,
right, that are all correct.
I would disagree, but go ahead.
Okay, but see, if you were to disagree,
if you look into the Bible, there's
almost the same exact things. And if you
really look back into history, the Bible
was brought in through Jesus. Correct.
No, but I understand what you're
No, but who was the Bible brought
through then?
A bunch of prophets. A bunch of
different prophets. Moses, Jeremiah,
Ezekiel, Joshua, you've talked about the
New Testament, you're talking about the
gospel. Jesus revealed the gospel, but
it was written by his apostles. So,
okay,
if you look into the Bible, the Zabur,
right, they're all the same exact thing
as the Quran, but the Bible, the Tawat,
and the Zabur were actually changed and
they were modified in different in like
throughout different centuries and
everything. Correct. But then that's
wrong.
Okay.
Correct.
The Quran doesn't even say that, sister.
Okay. But it is also sworn in the Quran
that the Quran will be like will be
preserved to the day of judgment. Okay.
The funny thing about the the it says it
doesn't say that about the Quran. It
says that about all of his scripture. It
says that Allah revealed send down the
reminder and he's the guardian of it.
[clears throat] Do you know what it
calls us in the Quran? It calls us the
people of the reminder, Jews and
Christians.
Okay. So the reminder, the Torah and the
Bible, the gospel, the reminder.
So the reminder is all of Allah's
revelation that he'll preserve, not just
one book.
Okay? But if you look into the Bible
like now, okay, and you look at one from
the 18th century, the 19th century, it's
not going to be the same. It's not going
to be the same. And there's verses in
the Quran that Allah swes like he swore
that the Quran would never get touched,
never get changed. Not a single like not
a single vowel will get changed.
But if I show you that there are vowels
and words that were changed would that
disprove the Quran?
No, because there's 10 different ways
the Quran can be read.
Ah, and similarly, there's 10 different
ways that the gospel could be written.
I didn't say written. I said read. Yeah,
there's Yeah, there's 10 different
there's 10 different kayat of the
gospel.
Besides that, and the wasn't part of the
Quran. They actually changed the Quran.
Yeah, there was no diiocritical marks at
first.
No one changed the Quran.
Yeah,
the Quran.
The Quran was put back together. If
you're talking about changing it,
you said it was put back together.
Yeah.
So, it used to be like apart
because Okay. when you get revelation
right Allah did not give Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the whole
Quran in one moment
he gave him certain ayat he gave him
certain verses he gave him certain suras
his first was that's the first surah
that's the first ayah that came down
really
yeah
Jabel Gabriel whatever how you pronounce
it he came down to him he told him he
told him I cannot read
how did Muhammad know it was Jabel
because what's it called all the other
prophets they also got revelation
through Jabaram Except for Mus Alam.
Musa Alam Mos or however you guys
pronounce it. He was he talked to Allah.
Yeah. But Muhammad didn't know about the
previous prophets before this. So how
did he know that this was Gabriel?
Yes, he did.
No, he didn't. He never read any of the
scriptures. He couldn't read.
He believed he believed from what his
what they taught him, what his family
taught him.
So who told him that this was Gabriel
that visited him in the cave?
Whoever raised him. Well, his wife
Khadijah told him that it could be
Jibaram.
Is is Kadada is Khadijah a prophet?
No, but that's something that she got
taught. No, no, no. That's something she
got taught. She got taught that all the
prophets got revelation through Jabaram
because if Allah listen, it said in a
verse that Musa Alisam asked Allah to
come down so he can see Allah. He didn't
even show a part of him and Musa Alam
passed out. Allah cannot come down
personally and speak to these
messengers. Huh?
He did like I just told you,
he did it to Moses.
He did not do that to Mo. No, he didn't.
Yeah, he he appeared in the fire to
Moses.
He showed a single part of him on top of
the mountain and the whole mountain
started shaking and Musa Alisam passed
out.
So that single part of him came into
creation and caused Muhammad caused
Moses to pass out, right? And the and
the mountain to crumble.
Yeah.
He g he gave a finger. I had to say it.
No finger. That's what it says. So, so
Allah is able to come to creation and
show himself.
Yes, he is. But if he were to the whole
earth would shake, people would pass
you. I just told you what happened to
Mus Alisam when Allah revealed a single
part of himself.
Okay, I got you. So, just going back to
this. So, Kadisha is not a prophet.
Muhammad, you know, didn't know
anything. Um, and so how did he how did
they know then that that Gabriel is the
one that appeared to him if they don't
they're not prophets. They don't they
don't know anything
because from the previous prophets from
the previous teachings Jam has came down
and revealed to the prophets. And how
are you going to tell me that Jiram is
not him? Because if Allah tala came down
if let me tell you let me tell you
if I'm with you I'm with you. It wasn't
Allah himself. Somebody Yeah, but here's
here's my thing. You said something
important. You said because of the
previous teachings, right, that you find
in the previous scriptures, okay? So
when we compare Gabriel in the previous
scriptures and that entity that came to
Muhammad in the cave,
we see that they're not the same.
Because never ever, and hear me, never
ever do you ever see Gabriel appear to
someone and they and he oppresses them.
He presses on them or forces them to try
to do something like read or recite or
something like that. He never scares
them out of their mind, but he always
brings peace and comfort to them. He
always says, "Do not be afraid." Right?
But here in the cave, this thing came
and oppressed Muham of Muhammad. Pressed
on him and squeezed him to the point
where Muhammad says he couldn't take it
anymore. Did this three times to him.
Okay.
Muhammad left the cave sweating and
fearful and he ran to Kada saying,
"Please cover me. Cover me." Because he
was afraid. He thought he But if do know
about revelation, getting revelation is
painful.
Says who?
Says teachings. Says
how are you going to tell me? No, no,
no. How are you, okay? Think about it
like yourself logically without Islam,
without Christianity. How are you going
to tell me that an angel that if he
spread his wings, he can cover the earth
and its universe comes down to you, it's
going to be all relaxed and chillax?
Yeah.
Cosmology to make the argument. So she's
using Islamic standards.
Yeah.
So you like like you said be based on we
got to base our stuff on previous
scriptures, right? Previous teaching. So
when we look at the previous teachings,
never do we ever see a prophet receive
revelation and it's painful. Never do
they go into are they afraid thinking
that they're demonpossessed. Never uh do
they believe that they encountered
something some evil force. But see,
okay,
it's never happened.
If you look into it more, after Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam went through
that, right, he actually thought to
himself that could have been a
revelation from Allah. And then once
Jubam did not come down for like a a
couple a couple months, he thought that
Allah was mad at him because Jubam did
not come down. So how are you going to
and what was he about to do because of
this?
I'm not knowledge about that. Well, he
was about to he went up to the high
mountain and was about to throw himself
down. He was suicidal.
Okay, please. Okay, we can talk and
everything, but for you to say something
about that about my prophet, I respect I
respect you. I respect your religion. I
respect, but I would highly appreciate
if you do not say stuff like that about
my prophet. We can talk, we can have an
adult conversation, but for you to say
about that to my prophet, that's no.
Yeah, lol
conversation. And in [clears throat]
adult conversations, you know, I I hard
truths are here. I'm not making fun of
Muhammad. That's literally what the
hadith says. It literally says that when
he when the revelation stopped coming to
him for a time, he would go up to the
high mountains and attempt to throw
himself off. He would try to unal alive
himself. This is not
from Bukari.
Okay,
I'll put on the screen. I I don't want
you to think that I'm mocking you or
making this up. I'm going show it to you
yourself. Okay.
Yeah, that's also even in the S also s
material all over.
Sib Bukari 698. Now this is the part I
was talking about. Um then Allah's
messenger return. So this is right after
his experience in the cave. It says then
Allah's messenger returned with the
inspiration his neck muscles twitching
with terror till he entered upon Cadesia
and said cover me. Cover me. They
covered him till his fear was over. And
then he said Cada what is wrong with me?
Right? Never do you see a prophet going
through this when they receive
revelation. This is this is what usually
we see. And I'm going to be real with
you. The Bible records reactions like
this with demonic possession, okay? With
demonic oppression,
okay? But demonic oppression also comes
with witch verses and all these I don't
even know how stuff like that works. But
obviously that's evil. But then if an
angel comes out tell you and then he
tells you a
read with the name of the Lord who
created you.
Yeah. But see the thing is Lean what
name of and what Lord is that because
there are a lot of false lords out there
that try to claim to be God.
Not at that time. Not at that time. At
that time there was just a lot and they
were statues are not capable of doing
stuff like that.
You're missing it. You're missing it.
See even the Bible says that all of
these like a lot of these false
religions come are doctrines from
demons. Like evil spirits are the
originators of these false religions and
doctrines leading people into believing
that they're worshiping a particular god
when really really they're worshiping
these evil spirits.
Okay. But how is an evil spirit going to
tell you a verse that has God's
It doesn't have his name. It doesn't say
what his name is.
What does mean? Means Lord.
Yeah. So what Lord? A lot of evil
spirits want to be referred to as the
Lord. What [clears throat] lord are you
are we talking about? That's not the
true Lord.
That's why read with the read with the
name of the one who's most merciful.
Okay? So, I'll show you this. Look, we
we'll get to that in a second. I'll
break down how we can [clears throat]
solidify um you know how this is evil.
I'll show you this. Okay? So, look. So,
Muhammad, you know, um after his
experience, they they calmed him down a
bit. All right? But after a few days,
Wara died and the divine inspiration was
also paused for a while. And the prophet
became so sad as we have heard that he
intended several times to throw himself
from the tops of high mountains.
Okay?
So this wasn't me making this up. I
wasn't mocking you. I wasn't or
anything. Right?
That proves that proves the dear love
that Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has for Allah that he fears that Allah
is what do you call it? Mad at him. And
if you if you know right prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was not 100
like he wasn't a prophet at that time he
was just a normal human being and all
prophets are mas means unable to sin so
if he was in prophethood during this
time he would not have done that he
couldn't have done that because mas is
unable you are like not able to sin has
made all of our prophets unable to sin
because of a sinful person
he was a prophet what are you talking
about this was after he received the
divine inspiration
multiple times. He was already a
prophet. That's why it calls him the
prophet. He did
because now, no, they call him the
prophet cuz it's respectful cuz you It's
referring to something that happened in
the past and he's a prophet. So, you
have to say the prophet received. So,
look what happens. What What are you if
you receive divine inspiration?
You're a prophet obviously, but does he
know is that does that that's the thing?
Does he know that?
Yes. Look, Bara told him this is after
all the Gabriel stuff. this is all after
all told him that you know oh you're a
prophet yada yada yada right all of this
stuff look even war said or replied in
the affirmative um that uh never did a
man come with something similar to what
you have brought but was treated with
hostility if I should remain alive uh
the day when you will be turned out then
I would support you strongly so he's
telling him that you're going to be
persecuted later and I and I will
support you cuz all [clears throat] the
prophets that came before you. They were
also treated with hostility. So he knows
he's a prophet now. Now after a few
days, Waraka died and the divine
inspiration was paused, right? And so
he's he's a prophet. He knows he's a
prophet now. But still, as a prophet, he
tried to throw himself off a cliff. You
know, prophets aren't perfect.
Prophets are per No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, [laughter] no. That's That's
where you're wrong. No. Well, am I wrong
here when it says Muhammad as a prophet
tried to commit?
Listen, I'm not educated about that
subject, that hadith ex that hadith,
that history, I'm not as educated about
that. But for you to go say that
prophets are no, they're not. They're my
All right, let me show you what the
Quran says. Okay, I'm going to show you
the Quran. The Quran says that Muhammad
committed sins in the past and will do
it in the future, but says that he will
forgive him of his past sins and his
future sins. Okay,
you do know that when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was younger,
right? I don't know if you know this or
not, but when you know how he went to
his uh what's it called? Foster mother
Hale,
do you know that?
No, I don't know that story.
Okay. So before you open up this, let me
tell you quickly about this quickly.
Why?
Okay. So back in the day of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's time and
like all the ancient times, they used to
go to foster mothers and grow up there
because it's more like it's more strict.
They teach you things, you know,
everything like that. Okay.
Okay.
And one day, Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was playing with Lawan has
children. Okay. And two angels carrying
a white I mean a gold like um tray kind
of. Okay. It had ice in it. And they
proceeded to grab Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam split his chest, grab
his heart and [snorts]
take out a clot which was like I guess
you can say the evil kind of and they
took it and they removed it and then
they put his heart back in. That proves
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
unable to sin. And Allah said that he
will forgive him no matter what.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
guaranteed for he's guaranteed
Jenna. He like there's no way he can
sin.
I hear you. All right. Now, let's get to
this verse now. Let's see if that's
actually true. Indeed, we have given
you, oh Muhammad, a clear conquest. Next
verse. that Allah may forgive you for
what preceded of your sin and what will
follow and complete his favor upon you
and guide you to the to a straight path.
That's Allah telling him that no matter
what you do, no matter what happens, I
will guarantee you made him Allah made
unable to sin. Allah made him sinless.
Calm down. Relax.
It says here that he is forgiving him
for what preceded of your sin. Now,
which means what he sinned in the past.
Let me give you an even clearer
translation so you can see this. That's
even worded weirdly. Look, that Allah
may forgive you your sins of the past
and the future and complete his favor on
you and guide you on the straight path.
That's Allah saying that he's forgiven
him 100%.
Yes, but of his past sins. He sinned in
the past. You see that?
Where be when he when he got his uh
chest split open or when when did he
sin?
Sister, whatever story you read of him
opening up his his chest. Either you're
misunderstanding what took place cuz it
doesn't
you can look that up in hadith. You can
look that up in the Quran. You can do so
much. That is 100% that that happened
from saying it's not sah. I'm talking
about your understanding of it. It
doesn't say that he can't sin. It
doesn't say that. This verse here in the
Quran explicitly says that Muhammad
sinned in the past and Allah forgives
him for it and he'll sin in the future
and Allah even forgives his sins in the
future.
That's Allah saying he's forgiven 100.
Like it doesn't matter.
Yeah, but he he still sin though. Do you
get it? He still sins but Allah forgives
him. He's good.
How are you going to tell me that
someone sinned if they have they had
like the entire the bad in them removed
and they're a prophet in their mus
they're unable to sin
because he unable to sin
because he didn't have the bad in him
removed.
Yeah. No, no, no. Do not tell me he did
not get the bad removed. Go look it up
in hadith. Go look it up in the Quran.
Go talk to a scholar. They will tell you
that that story is 100% it happened and
it's literally it's it's in hadith. It's
in the Quran. And then after that's
children went to her and they told her
that this is and this and that and then
she took it back to Medina.
Can you open 4719 as well?
Yeah.
What is after this? Yeah. 4719.
I need you to I need you to like this.
Yeah. After this please lay what has the
authority Quran or Hadith?
Quran 100%. It's the words of Allah
according to this verse. Now be honest
with me. You know we've been talking so
far. You you you understand stuff.
You're you could be logical so be honest
with me. According to this verse, it
says that Muhammad sinned in the past.
Right? And
so you may forgive your sins in the
past. Correct.
Right. So that he sinned.
But then if you put two and two
together, if you put two and two
together, someone does a prophet.
Correct. If a prophet Okay. Okay. Wait.
No, no, no. Sir, sir, sir. Put this put
this verse aside for a minute. If a
person came down to you,
did he sin in the past according to the
verse? Please. Let me speak and then we
can come back to
I need you to answer the question. You
can elaborate however you want.
I believe I believe as a Muslim that all
prophets are sinless. They are unable to
sin.
What does this verse say? Does this
verse say listen if all if all prophets
are sinless? How can he sin?
Because all prophets are not sinless.
Yes, all prophets are sinless. How can a
if someone comes down to sir as an
educated man as mah I can't say much
love for you but like you're very
educated correct
they say I know more more about Islam
than most Muslims in the world
I wouldn't say that because that's not
that's my not my opinion okay but if
someone comes down to you and tells you
believe in this and that and this god is
that and this prophet is that but they
go and sin they go and drink they go and
kill they go and do this they go and do
that they go and do this they do all
these sinful things would you believe
them they go and lie would
believe that they're not a prophet and
that see
exactly so you can't believe what they
said
salam that's why we reject Muhammad